hey guys pete here it's time for another
live discussion
this time we'll be discussing episode
four of better call saul's final season
this one had some fun moments which
helped to transition from the heavy
episode last week and
it's not an easy job you know we
every episode can't end with this
massive
you know thing that's going to change
everything and make us feel
something for weeks to come and i think
it generally did a pretty good job of
doing that
more so i'm really interested in some of
the character developments and i wanted
to talk to you know i wanted to come
here i wanted to talk about that and
discuss it with my guest
and i think there's a lot of stuff
happening around identity in this
episode um
who these characters are and who they're
pretending to be
that's sort of front and center in this
episode so
why don't you identify yourself and give
me your overall thoughts on episode 604
which is an episode directed by kim
wexler herself ray seehorn
and then we'll talk our way through what
happened
sure i'm gil and uh you can find me over
on the one take youtube channel or on
sawcast the podcast i do dedicated to
better call saul
uh i do that with my younger brother who
sometimes joins me on these streams but
find solo tonight
overall you know i agree with everything
you said where the tone of this episode
was a little bit different from last
week which i think was to be expected
you're not going to have a character
facing his impending death
every week
and i think it's appropriate you know
you don't want to always be flooring it
you want to sometimes slow down change
the tone a little bit so you can
actually feel it when you go back to
that intensity um so it's a much more
fun episode i remember noticing last
night watching it there was a lot of
music in the episode more than i think
we typically have and that definitely
contributed to that tone
there were a lot of parts that had me
laughing out loud which i'm sure we'll
get into but having said that the
intensity wasn't gone even when we were
laughing my heart was still racing you
know i remember jimmy pulling that sign
out of the ground while howard is
walking right above him and you're
wondering if he's going to get caught
right there
you had bill oakley and everyone at the
courthouse turning on jimmy that didn't
feel great and then of course the moment
of kim and mike finally meeting for the
first time on screen
so it was a little bit of a different
tone a little bit more fun but the
intensity was still there and you know
it's leading to
something pretty interesting so overall
really solid episode definitely wouldn't
call it filler i saw some people in the
comments saying that over um we were
talking about it last night so yeah
another solid episode and better call
saul's final season
yeah
that that's the thing that you know
that's a thing that the internet likes
to throw around a little too liberally i
think that idea of filler um
character is important especially in a
show like this and
you need to you know you need to give
them moments to to do what they do so
that we understand who they are when
they make decisions you know it's
certainly
an important part of what makes this
such a good show and i'll tell you i i
was looking at comments right before i
came in here and i've been noticing over
the last um
you know over this season
it stands out to me how some people are
saying things like
the the gym the jimmy and kim part of
this is a total waste of time why don't
they get to the real story and it's sort
of like wait this is a show about jimmy
mcgill turning into saul goodman you
know
it's in the breaking bad universe and
you know we saw a lot of the the
crossover
today but this is this isn't the story
of gus fring you know this is the story
of jimmy mcgill and um
i think you know once we got we had that
really heartfelt like heart-wrenching
episode about nacho you know we we
needed to get back into
where you know into the main story and i
thought it was a good send-off for him i
mean we've talked about that already and
i think that
we see here that things are setting up
to be pretty insane
moving towards the ending i'm still not
really you know it's still pretty hard
to say how how things are gonna play out
but it it's certainly gonna be a fun
ride and i think that this episode
did a good job of setting that up
so we'll go through everything that
happened here
and um we'll just sort of uh we'll give
our thoughts and then anytime you know
if you guys have questions we'll try to
to incorporate those but we'll also take
some time at the end and
throw it out for q a so we start out
with this teaser and
i i l you know this is one of the things
i like about
how you know both of these shows both
series is how they
they utilize this opening teaser the
cold open kind of thing
and um
this one just it just was was bizarre
you know i'm like who i'm sure these
people are important but i can't exactly
figure out why they're track you know
these matching track suits and the whole
thing like
where does this fit in and and these
people were like
so engaged in the neighborhood you know
they're talking about the homeowners
association and how they're not going to
you know accept this color of red and
you know it was really
it was a really great
you know opening shot inside their house
where you see these people sitting there
and you really don't get it you know i
mean you see the monitor so if you saw
the teasers then you know it all comes
together pretty quickly but you know i
think that there's a there's a
possibility that if you weren't really
paying that close of attention
you don't remember what gus springs
house looks like first you know for
instance and then this is like
completely out of place until till it
comes back together later what were your
impressions of this uh teaser
yeah so first it had me laughing just
because it's such a mundane conversation
and you know that they have to be
showing it to you for a reason but after
the intensity of last week to now open
on two characters debating the most
accurate description of the color of red
that they both find so detestable in
their neighborhood and then where
exactly does the line end for their
neighborhood that they have kind of
scope over so it had me laughing and
then i also remembered the name of the
episode hit and run and i'm like are
they about to get hit by a car and it's
howard's car and they're framing him for
it for something oh
and then once we saw this family
once they were in the house
uh some part of me started to wonder if
this had something to do with gus
and i don't know if i was just
subliminally remembering or
subconsciously remembering what gus's
house looks like from breaking bad uh
and i think at the end of the teaser
there is that very prominent zoom in
where you see the address 1213 on the
house
which again if you remember gus's house
that was his address and of course you
see the guy with the gun you see the
security so you start to realize there's
more going on here than just two people
walking around having a conversation
so it was a really
fun opening that had me laughing and
then also as always with the show it's
never just laughing or it's usually not
just laughing that's also usually joined
by one cocked eyebrow of or what's
what's going on here
yeah i mean
my initial impression was that that they
didn't actually interact with the people
that were there they were just sort of
minding their business living their
lives
pretending that none of that was
happening i i had i mentioned that in my
video and some people commented that um
that maybe they did interact a bit and i
just didn't notice it and i haven't had
a chance to go back and look but it was
so bizarre and they were perfect and and
we'll come back to this later because
we'll have to talk about gus and his
his fortress that he has there and his
his defense system that he's got
employed but
yeah i i and i also really like the
music you know they they did this and
when i was watching when i was when i
was pulling clips for for my video i i
you know i went back and watched the
wendy uh intro episode
that teaser from
breaking bad
and they had that great pop song in the
beginning of that um
wendy you know
and it reminded me that there was a
little bit of a mineco or you know there
was a little bit of a rhyme between
those two two openers that have the uh
the same type of song there
we don't like i said we'll come back to
these these people and what's going on
at gus's house because we get you know
the the next big thing is the plan they
put their plan in motion to go after
cliff maine and and if you want to you
can
you can give your impressions of that uh
you can go first
yeah um so we finally find out what
their whole ruse was
involving howard's car
and basically they
kim goes to meet cliff for lunch and
while they're talking
jimmy dressed up to look like howard
speeds by kicks wendy out of his car so
in cliff's mind he's just witnessed
howard
very rudely kick a prostitute out of his
car and speed off is there an unrude way
to do that
that's a great question
um but just so many levels of humor in
this like number one the call back to
season one the first time we saw jimmy
dress himself up to look exactly like
howard it was hilarious and then the
fact that we get to see it again here
just made me laugh out loud
and then jimmy once again leaning into
his prostitute scam from last season
where he has them show up at lunch with
cliff
and uh demand payment saying that um you
know you owe us some money
so that whole thing was pretty fun to
watch
and it's also really clever on their
part the way they're going about this
because we've talked a couple times and
i think our previous live streams where
at some point you've got to think howard
is going to catch on that maybe jimmy is
up to something behind the scenes
but at least since the little baggie of
drugs incident
everything they've been doing has been
working on cliff so howard doesn't
necessarily know that anything is amiss
he has no idea that cliff has just
witnessed this thing so they're buying
themselves time
before anyone catches on that there's
something strange going on behind the
scenes
yeah i i gotta say that the opening shot
um of jimmy you see him from behind
you see the fob so you know that this is
the plan and
i was under the impression that that
they might hire somebody to be howard
you know i mean there was obvious
it was obvious that he had the suit from
before and there was you know that was a
choice that would you know
would
weigh into their their decision making
but i thought maybe they might have
someone else
and the way that they transform bob
odenkirk
into howard i mean like it made you it
made me do a double take when i first i
mean
he was a different person he really they
really uh
really made that work the way that he
looked like howard in that shot yeah you
buy that wendy would be so struck by the
way he looks that she would just sit
there in the car staring at him
yeah she she was mesmerized by her hair
and i have to admit you know i have to
agree with her it did look
good and he had like the bronzer on or
the fake tan whatever that is you know
like it was
it was it was really fantastic and
um you know it it comes down to this
idea that i was thinking about here
which is this you know this idea of
identity and
who they're pretending to be and you
know like
what they're doing right now and how
that's going to define who they're going
to be later you know what i mean how
people see them maybe how they see
themselves
and um you know it's like here you see
jimmy he can jump right into that role
you know he can be
howard hamlin for an hour you know what
i mean he can throw a prostitute out of
his car he can speed back there he can
make up this
fantastic audible you know where he
pulls the sign out of the out of the
ground
and he can and he can move between that
those two two personalities and
as the episode goes on you'll see more
of this and we'll talk more about it
about how
who they are underneath how that sort of
comes out right and how people you know
how people are are thinking about them
and you know jimmy especially he's kind
of
he's kind of between two worlds and he's
not really accepted in either one of
them you know
and
and we see that in this scene that he's
most comfortable whenever he's doing
this sort of thing and it makes me
wonder because we don't really know
about kim's background not not not that
much about it
you know who is who is kim wexler and
you know
where is she most comfortable i mean
we've seen her that she's absolutely
competent in the in the world of of
being a lawyer that she's worked her way
up into
but um you know there i feel like
there's another layer coming there and
and i like that they're setting that up
in in this way that you know we really
don't know you know yeah for for jimmy
we've definitely seen a transformation
where they've shown us various glimpses
of jimmy mcgill at different points in
his life and so i think with him we have
a little bit more of a solid idea
of what was beneath the surface that
we're learning about and what has
actually changed over the course of the
series versus kim where i feel like
we're definitely seeing her change but
there's also a lot of questions of what
are we seeing that was already there and
what's actually new that's growing out
of her experiences in the course of this
series
yeah because i get i get a lot of
comments or sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt but i just wanted to add that
you know
i've been getting a lot of comments
where people are saying they don't buy
her transition
but we don't know
how much she changed to become the
person that we knew at hhm like you said
you know we don't we don't know what her
baseline is we just know what she was
doing whenever we met her where she is
at
yeah exactly and we've seen her make
some pretty drastic decisions
in response to
life and death experiences
after her car crash she completely
reassessed her priorities and decided
i do not want to spend my life
representing a giant bank like mesa
verde i want to help people who need it
and we saw her
rededicate herself to um
uh pro bono work and then
this season six is now taking place
after she nearly lost jimmy and then
faced off against lalo
so nearly lost her own life so she's
been through a few traumatic experiences
that hey yes there are things below the
surface we don't really know her
baseline we don't know how much we're
just stripping away things that kind of
piled up on the surface and now we're
getting to the real kim and on top of
that she's been through some traumatic
experiences that would either alter a
person or verily very rapidly chip away
at those layers of
falsehood that you put on top of who you
really are
yeah and we'll come back around to that
when we talk about her meeting with mike
because
that was something that really the
you know came out for me and that and
you know the way that they're thinking
about jimmy
and what's going on with him and his
ptsd after after that whole end of
season five but then like
you know the she was there too you know
what i mean so you know that she's but
she's going through something as well
and i feel like she's kind of
that felt like
you know she's kind of closing that off
and just being like well i need to do
this to protect jimmy
rather than like you know
what's really going on here and real
quick i wanted to just touch on this uh
this live or
touch on this super chat from thomas
cunningham thank you for the five
dollars he says hey pete and gill i love
the live
streams i'm wondering how and when
howard will finally catch on to kim and
jimmy any theories
yeah we we've we've discussed this a bit
in the past i mean my my thinking is
soon
um
i i feel like cliff is gonna is going to
he has to
uh confront
howard at one point you know i think
that's coming soon and um
howard knows he didn't do it you know
like he knows that he didn't he wasn't
there that this thing didn't happen
so i think that
it's only natural that he's going to
suspect jimmy uh maybe not kim right in
the beginning but i mean i think that
that's a natural
thing that he has to do i've been
talking about this for a while
i think the question for me more has
been that
are they anticipating this like kim and
jimmy are smart so they know that
he would he you know they know that he
would uh
suspect them so what's their plan
how does that fit into their plan i
guess is more of what i'm thinking do
you want to add anything to that gill
uh yeah the one thing i'd add is that
before this season started i remember
the the theory i was thinking a lot
about
is maybe howard doesn't find out maybe
jimmy and kim are successful and maybe
they're more successful than they
expected to be because i think we we
don't expect this to just work out
perfectly it would be pretty boring if
it did or i'm sure if it did work out
perfectly the writers would still find a
way to make that interesting and it
leads to something else but i assume
that somehow this goes wrong and that
can happen either by howard catching on
to them and kind of fighting back or
what if they're so successful that they
don't just bruise him a little but
completely destroy his career
maybe he
we see hints that i mean i guess i never
really thought about howard's personal
life but here he talks about a wife it
seems therapist and i was like oh yeah
he does have a ring on his hand you know
maybe they destroy a family
and uh maybe that drives howard to a
really dark place and there's some blow
back after the plan is successful and
that might lead to something interesting
so i guess that's a long way of saying
whatever happens i think it's going to
be something unexpected i don't
necessarily take it for granted that
howard will find out before they're
successful
yeah
i mean i i've talked about this uh you
know in the past and i i think they made
a real effort the the you know the the
show has made a real effort to make us
like howard again you know
um
they made him sympathetic over the last
two seasons and that therapy session did
uh stand out to me
there have been vague hints you know
like you said he wears a ring and there
were vague hints that he he had a wife
but
here he's talking about like there being
problems at home and it bothering him
you know what i mean and
it gave him a little more humanity just
like clint cliffs mentioning his uh
son's drug problems you know they were
they were kind of like
this is gonna feel sad whenever jimmy
and
and kim are successful here because
these people aren't all bad you know
what i mean
so well it'll i don't know we'll see um
we'll see how they're planning that out
because
this is uh you know they're pretty good
at this everybody is uh
everybody is formidable in this
situation in one way or the other
i have another super chat here from
larry
quartowitz
thank you for the five dollars hey pete
been a fan of yours for a while but this
is my first live stream do you think the
house in season six episode one is saul
and kim's house in breaking bad or just
his
my belief is it is just his that kim
wexler does not currently live in that
house
uh i feel pretty strongly about that
yeah but you know but i could be wrong
you know the thing about that house that
that i haven't really um
you know i've been thinking about it you
know we had another one of those
pre-easter eggs this week where we saw
the beanie baby that's there
and i'm wondering if they're going to do
one
per episode kind of thing like where
they did the uh painting last week and
and now the the beanie baby and
next week we're gonna have you know some
another one that shows up there but
you know i've been wondering about why
anybody would live in that house you
know why
it's it's a little hard to understand
how you know i i know that there's the
idea that
he played the part and then he became
the part
but you know there could be other
reasons on why he's playing that up so
much
but either way
you know unless she's there and she's on
board for that
i'm just not buying it
yeah i laughed um when you started
answering the question just because
we've spent so much time you and i kind
of discussing this question
and i i definitely agree like if i were
betting my money i would say it's just
jimmy um but i've also mentioned that i
don't think it's completely impossible
that kim would be there the thing that
initially made me ask the question is
when we see kim advising jimmy what kind
of car would saul goodman drive what
kind of office would saul goodman have
so i could see her saying what kind of
toilet would saw goodman have right it
would be gold-plated
but then of course you can counter that
by saying this is his private life it's
not a public thing that people are
seeing at least we wouldn't expect it to
be so that line of thinking just got me
to wonder if maybe kim would be there
and she just does see it all as a facade
but as a necessary one
so i think it's possible but i do agree
with you ultimately if i put my money
down i'd say it's just jimmy
yeah um
it's a great way to open
open this season um i'm so happy they
did and i just so i don't forget later
i think it's really funny to see how gus
lives compared to how we imagine that
that uh saul goodman lives you know
yeah true
it's a great it's a great um
you know there's a
they couldn't be more different um
we have another one here from shrimp
thank you for the five dollars
he says when you play the game of meth
empires either you win or you get put in
a barrel
there's no middle ground
well
you know this is a prequel and we do
know how things end for a lot of people
and um
you know
kim is
you know i was thinking about this this
morning whenever i was getting ready
here uh you know kim
is the big question mark now we we've
gotten nacho
we know how his end
you know was so
what do you think you think we got um
kim in a barrel at some point yeah
well first i would i would respond to
this statement by saying i think it's
more like you win until you get put in a
barrel like i think breaking bad and
better call saul are both shows that
have they take place in a karmic
universe where morality is sort of
inescapable it feels like if you're a
bad person
eventually you get what's coming to you
by the end of breaking bad i mean
basically everybody
that we knew as a villain was dead
including walter white um the only one
who got away was that was jesse
so
i think it's it's sort of in this world
you get what you deserve but the
question is what do you deserve
and i think that's kind of the question
looming for jimmy mcgill
uh you know you see when he in another
way to put that question is when he
becomes saul goodman how much of that is
an act how much of his soul is still in
there is he regretful is there a way to
make up for some of the bad he's done is
that even possible
uh yeah
yeah and with kim i mean it's such a
question mark i i'm so curious to see
how she thinks about all this stuff how
much is she compartmentalizing
uh the fact that you know she says to
jimmy you can
uh you could go to the d.a about lalo
you could be a rat or you could be a
friend of the cartel basically advising
him you don't want to be a rat is she
thinking about fred whalen is she
thinking about the innocent people that
have been killed by this drug trade or
is she completely compartmentalizing and
for me to understand morally where she
sits i need to see the answers to those
questions
and i think we're of course going to see
her get pushed a lot this season
and probably have to confront some
pretty tough questions like that like
maybe at some point reckon with the fact
that she's not really destroying howard
purely out of the good of her heart
there's some personal vendetta there we
need to see her reckon with those
questions and then i can start to think
about what does kim deserve
and and then we can speculate on where
she ends up
yeah that that is an interesting um
twist on that question that hangs over
the series uh
what does not just what jimmy deserves
but what does kim deserve you know
we uh
it's
it's almost impossible to tell
and that's pretty that's pretty
fascinating considering that we we know
where you know like you said i don't i
don't think that she i think she does
just sort of compartmentalize at all you
know i think that
she sees
what she wants to see in that
they can do they can do something good
they can they can provide this kind of
uh you know
they can they can provide representation
for people who can't get can't get it
who are slipping through the cracks and
howard will recover ultimately you know
it's the kind of thing you tell yourself
but you know that you don't have control
on how everything plays out so that's
why you know you wouldn't do it because
it may in fact ruin his career it may in
fact ruin his family
you know there's so many different
things that that just are out of your
control so
yeah i think actually we see there's a
couple of things that happen in this
episode which i think speak pretty
directly to that point i think jimmy and
kim they feel like they have the world
in the palm of their hands they are the
master manipulators and we see a great
example where they're not as smart as
they think they are like that i saw
somebody in the in the chat mention it
was a little silly of them to think that
that cone was going to do the job then
no one's going to move it and i can
picture a scene where kim says you think
that this cone will be enough and i see
i've gone completely out of focus here
i'll get my tech guy in here to help
with that in a second but i could see i
can imagine a scene where kim says you
think this cone is gonna work
and then jimmy says nobody ever touches
an orange cone like they think they're
so smart and then they find out they
can't predict how things are gonna work
out as well as they think they can
and then i also think you see them get
called out uh when jimmy's at the
courthouse and everyone's kind of turned
on him that's a moment where jimmy
thinks he can get away with all this he
can have his cake and eat it too but
here you see a real blowback you can't
just walk around do whatever you want
and not think it's going to damage your
reputation somehow
yeah and that that's always the thing
with with the scams you know like jimmy
gets focused in
on on can this be done
you know not what's gonna happen after
it happens you know what i mean like and
that that's really that's kind of what
you know chuck used to say about him
that you know it kind of that's kind of
where chuck was pulling that from
so we have a super chat from andy lopez
i don't know what cop 10000 is but thank
you for that
do you think that kim will tell us all
about lalo
how was how will she tell him
i've been thinking about this too um
it's obviously a choice that she made
not to do that and and we'll get into
that a little bit later
i think it's gonna hap i think she's
going to have to
um
i think that based on what he says later
in the you know in the when his first
introduced in breaking bad that he's
still
really afraid of lalo um even though lol
is probably dead there
this is kind of all a setup for that
like he thinks he's dead for a while and
then he finds out he's not and then
he'll never really kind of accept if
he's dead or not after that you know
what i mean like he'll always be scared
what do you what do you think um you
know i mean
yeah i think it depends a little bit on
why you think kim didn't tell saul about
lalo at the end of the episode
uh and i've seen a couple different
ideas on that one that i heard is she
just
felt bad for jimmy and kind of didn't
want to he was excited about the new
office and it just wasn't the right
moment to give him this
uh disturbing news
but the way i read it was more
that she really took to heart what mike
said that she's made of sterner stuff
and so she's decided to kind of
uh
carry the burden of this she's not going
to tell jimmy about it and worry him
she's going to worry about it because
there's really nothing they can do about
it at the moment and we already saw last
season that jimmy freaked out when he
thought lala was out there he didn't
want kim to go to work and she was the
one who said we've got to move on with
our lives so we've seen the dynamic
where she knows how to take this and to
use the word again compartmentalize just
put it away we've got to move forward
and i think that's what she's decided to
do so if she tells jimmy
i think it'll be out of necessity
they'll be in a situation where she has
no choice but to tell him like they're
being pursued we need to run and i can't
come up with a fake reason why so jimmy
lola's still alive we gotta go something
along those lines
yeah that's that's my feeling too is
this gonna come out and this is kind of
a good transition into
you know what happens next um
the
the this that that the conversation that
they have at their at their apartment
and and the idea of being followed and
um
the way that they the way that the the
writers they had they had jimmy step up
in this in this in this instance to
calm
calm kim you know which is like the flip
of what we saw them doing earlier you
know she was the one that was saying hey
everything's gonna be all right and
you know now
we've got
that turned around and
i think that um
where where were
they i think that they're at the point
where they can't actually stop anymore
they don't really stop and consider what
they're doing because you know you were
just saying that they they need you know
he she needs to tell him because
something's happening and the real
question is
do they need to be doing this with
howard anymore
you know she met with cliff he was
interested in helping her out
jimmy was always going to get the
sandpiper money you know they're being
presented with these ideas that actually
this isn't really important you know
like what they're doing with howard
but at the same time all of their
decisions seem to
you know
all the situations they find themselves
in they seem to just be pushing each
other along and they don't really seem
capable of saying maybe we should pull
back anymore
yeah and i completely agree with that i
think
you know kim makes a point of saying to
jimmy when she brings up the fact that
cliff actually went for her idea she
brings up the fact that you know cliff
isn't gonna write any checks
so i think that was partially to say hey
we still need the sandpiper money
but do they really need it i mean i
think the answer to that is no she could
work something out with cliff we start
small they have fundraisers i mean there
are ways to get money
and to your point they will eventually
get that money so you can always start
small and kind of build the practice
more and more as time goes on and you
make more money
but yeah i don't think they need it you
know i think that's not really why
they're doing it that's just the
justification they tell themselves
yeah and that and that that goes back to
like what is kim
really trying to accomplish because i
see a lot of people that are also asking
the question of like
why are they doing this you know and and
do we know do you think you know i mean
i know
that the the end goal is for
um
is for them to have or is for kim to
have this practice
but the but but it's also personal
against howard and we we know that you
know he kind of took out his
grievances of having to be under chuck
and having to deal with chuck
being irrational when it came to jimmy
he kind of took that out on kim and he
was a bad boss like he was definitely
not a great guy and and he and he never
really
made up for that in any way and you know
eventually she just left
right so i mean i get that all but i
mean it feels like there's something
more
that you know hasn't hasn't yet been
revealed to make that crystal clear yeah
i don't think we can say with certainty
that we know her entire motivation here
but i think what's at least hinted at
is she definitely sees a system that she
doesn't like a system that rewards
people like howard hamlin that rewards
people like ken the first person they
scammed back at the beginning of season
two and
i think she's kind of taking out some
bigger feelings on howard
than just howard he's kind of the
representation of this system
that rewards him just because he was
born to the right person
uh so it's a little bit of robin hood
right she wants to help people that
don't have the same opportunity as him
um but she also wants to rail against
the system and i think that feeling is
also why when jimmy invited her into
slipping jimmy's schemes for the first
time it was so exhilarating for her
because it was a chance for her to kind
of rebel against this thing that she
sees so wrong with the world
so yeah to me it's not just about
punishing howard it's about punishing
what howard represents
yeah i think that's definitely the case
um
you know i've said that you know in
different points and
you know i just think that um
i wonder if jimmy knows you know i
wonder if jimmy really gets it because
jimmy has his own beef with howard you
know he has his own reasons to move
forward and and he actually
was very hesitant and didn't think
howard deserved what they were trying to
do
and like we know what what you know we
know where his his beef is you know what
i mean yeah and i think jimmy was kind
of satisfied with little pranks
just giving howard a bad day here and
there
um but yeah i agree once kim pushes for
something that might do some real damage
jimmy is hesitant and i think if you
were to ask him why kim wants to do this
i think he would tell you well she wants
to get the sandpiper money that's what
it's all about
i don't know that he knows everything
worth talking about here in terms of her
real motivations i don't know that jimmy
is aware of any of that
yeah i think he sensed something i think
he saw that in
in 510 in the finale of season five i
think he sensed something or he realized
that there might be more that he didn't
previously understand about this woman
that he's kind of been in a relationship
with a long time at that point
but i don't think he's had anything that
has proven any you know there's no
there's nothing that it had it never
really moved forward from there it's
just that he sees that she's
all in on trying to get this practice so
um we have a we have a super chat from
akumador
mx5555 that looks nice that that looks
i'm not sure what that is but that's a
that's a
a nice looking number and
while most
cartels gus cartels eladio mike walt
nacho died
lalo kim and saul could be alive
i'll die in the series or only these are
live
um
i think
none i think lalo's gonna die i don't
think kim and saul are gonna die though
what do you think gail no yeah i think i
mean the lala one is funny because
there's so much back and forth around
this
you know you could if you want to know
is he alive or not during breaking bad
if you want to believe that he is alive
you point to the jimmy line uh lalo
didn't send you if he thinks that
somebody might if he thinks lalo might
have sent people after him at least
jimmy thinks lalo is alive if you want
to think lalo's definitely dead by the
time you get to breaking bad
a it seems unlikely he'd be alive and
not at all involved in the salamancas
that we saw in that series and b gus
tells hector salamanca you know
something along the lines of with your
death the entire salamanca line is over
so gus believes he's dead so i think
most signs point to lalo is not alive
during breaking bad and uh
jimmy and kim their ultimate fates i
mean big question marks you know we'll
see
yeah yeah i i had seen someone kept
mentioning this in the comments and
that's something that i've talked about
in previous videos
i tend to think that gus is a better
source you know
we have those two competing things like
you said i think gus would know i think
we can we can kind of believe him
but then again lalo is pretty
uh he he showed himself to be pretty
dynamic and resourceful and you know
it's anything's possible let me tell you
this
lalo is not the kind of guy that only
has one body double
[Laughter]
yeah it's that's
if you got one why not have a few you
know it actually uh stu brings up a good
point which is lalo could be alive at
the beginning of season it could be
alive at the beginning of season two
when saul says oh lola didn't send you
but by the time we get to gus's death
then he's dead
yeah and that that's that's been brought
up on on in those discussions uh you
know on reddit and elsewhere over the
years it's definite possibility
i think that we're you know we're
definitely going to be doing some flash
forwards i felt i feel more certain
about that than than i you know ever
have as far as where we're at in the
story right now so it's possible
i just think that you know i i mentioned
this in my video yesterday i i it dawned
on me
that
we were we were doing this thing where
you know everything was super tense with
nacho and
heavy and you know
i had seen that gordon smith and but
they asked him about what the rest of
the season was like and he said darker
and this was this was before the end of
of you know this before episode four
came out it was in between or whatever
and
i was thinking you know how much darker
can it get you know right
nacho he he he took his life to
sacrifice look just for the hope that
maybe he could save his father you know
what i mean because every because he had
no other choice like he was just caught
in the worst situation you can imagine
and it dawned on me you know in the
between here and that
it can get a lot darker because of lalo
you know
of course kim and her her fate is also
another thing but you know lalo can
bring some real darkness and and
you know that we might just be in the in
the transition from the darkness of of
what we had in the beginning to the real
darkness and um
let's get to these super chats before
we lose track of what's happening here
um another one from larry
quartzowitz five dollars thank you i
think kim is doing the pro bono work to
make up for her scheming which she feels
inclined to do
she sees that mike also broke bad now
and relates
you what do you think about that uh well
thinking about that first sentence that
i'm not sure i agree with because i
don't think that kim thinks of her
scheming
as as wrong
i think a lot of what we've seen from
her is that she sort of justifies it
because of the target
and
i mean it's hard to say where her head's
at now um
but i don't think that she's having the
same hesitation as jimmy around going
after howard i think she's a little
rattled by being followed but i don't
think she's having second thoughts at
all about going after howard at least at
least not yet
um
yeah i don't think we've seen that
confirmed in any way
yeah so i don't i don't see that as her
trying to balance the scales for for
scheming if anything actually i think
she'd feel inclined to do pro bono work
because she might feel bad about all the
work she did for mesa verde and just
supporting again the system that is
willing to kick a guy out of his house
uh and offer him what she would consider
to be not nearly enough to make up for
taking away the home he's had for
decades
um so if anything i think that's what
she'd be trying to kind of balance the
scales for
yeah and i i think that yeah that was my
take on it was it was similar to yours
that um
the pro bono work was her way of trying
to stay in the corporate world and
be able to do something that was
satisfying because she just wasn't happy
there and like everyone you know howard
said it to her in the courthouse at the
end of 5 10 you know it's like nobody
would nobody would quit your job
nobody you know it's she had it made she
was on the partner track at a really
successful firm and she would have been
absolutely successful at the end
you know
so
that was her way of kind of like maybe
if i do this then i can do the thing i
should be doing that everyone says i
should be doing and um
you know i i i
he mentions this idea about mic breaking
bad and and relates and
do you want to get into that now or do
you want to wait until we talk about
their conversation
uh let's wait that'll give me a chance
to think about it yeah and and larry if
if we somehow smooth over that later
just start spamming the chat so that you
see what you're saying because
it's a good question and i just i just
don't want to get too derailed at the
moment because i know that there's a lot
of stuff that we're going to talk about
it in a few minutes
so thanks again for the five
we got one here from
sumatrasics 499 almost as good as five
thank you for that um
the wicked flea sounds like it came
straight from chuck
what do you think that says about where
jimmy's head is
ethics guilt or grief well that is from
a proverb and i don't have it in front
of me
but it's about that you know it's about
that you always have to look over your
shoulder when you you know when you
start doing things
like what they're doing and um
you know it i don't know where his head
is but i saw how he reacted to her
saying that and the way he reacted was
to say hey
you're just you just we got away with it
and that's bothering you believe me i
know because i've done this kind of
thing before
and he said you know
it's natural basically that you feel
like somebody's watching you but
nobody's watching you because we are the
only ones who know what we're doing
and
for one she finds out a little bit later
that that's not true they've been
they're being followed everywhere so
somebody else knows they probably don't
care but it brings up the point that
even though they're being really smart
and trying their best to
to plan it nothing is you know there's
there's so many variables something can
always go wrong
and i think that you know what that
scene tells me is that jimmy's head is
it doesn't matter how i feel about this
it what matters is
being there for kim because you know
this is what matters to me
and i think he's i think he's a long
time ago stuffed all the grief
all the guilt and all that stuff and it
just comes up i mean you see it flare up
in different points he definitely felt
that when he was at the courthouse and
nobody wanted to be his friend anymore
but i think the way that he's dealing
with that is he's just sort of saying
well look it doesn't really matter about
me i just got to be there for kim
yeah i think that's exactly right and i
think it's a it's a hard question to
answer cleanly
especially when it comes to ethics
because i think jimmy's kind of all over
the place on that i mean of course he
has some basic humanity where he was
pretty torn up about the fact that fred
whalen was killed
um but
certain things that we might not do like
we won't go and try to swindle somebody
to steal money from them
but he justifies all that because you go
all the way back to when he was a child
and kind of learn that lesson
there's wolves and sheep in the world if
you're not a wolf you're a sheep and
you're getting taken advantage of so you
can kind of justify your actions by
saying i'm going after people but only
because they're all against me and
that's kind of a weird balancing act of
morality because that's not necessarily
true all the time
so i think a lot of what we're seeing
this season and last season is taking
that to its logical conclusion now that
jimmy's getting involved in higher
stakes things he's starting to see that
now you're dealing with life-and-death
situations
some things that jimmy would frown upon
are happening
so
he's going to a feel conflicted
and it be like you said probably deal
with it the same way he dealt with his
grief over chuck's death by kind of
stuffing it down not dealing with it
focusing on something else like making
kim feel better in this moment
um yeah and i i put this up here because
that was what the the quote the way that
i understand the proverb was the wicked
flea when no man pursueth i think is was
the way that i i i was thinking about it
did i mischaracterize that because i saw
somebody
seem to think so in the comments um
i think that's essentially what you said
yeah i think that's what that was that's
what that's about right that you know
you know you're
you're worried even when there's no
reason to be just because of your
actions you know the things that you're
doing make you worry
right you know that's exactly how i read
it yeah when you're wicked you you think
you're being chased you flee
even though there's nobody there because
that that's how your guilt manifests
yeah
so um
i guess maybe we can move on we've
touched on a couple of things already
like i said jimmy at the the courthouse
the beanie baby situation um
that was a really great i i think
with so many other things going on you
kind of overlooked that scene but bob
odenkirk really delivered uh a great
little
performance in that and that um being
the set what was the the beanie baby was
it a penguin or something like um oh man
yeah i don't know what animal it was
actually meant to represent i just
remember a small white fluffy animal
with uh was it a graduation cap
yeah i don't have any opposable thumbs
[Laughter]
i can't sign the form because i don't
have any imposable thumbs it was a yeah
it was funny as as hell i thought and
really just um
you know it
jimmy has put in so much time you know
that's so important to him is to get
these people to like him over there
it's just a part of who he is and to see
that all snatched away is pretty
fantastic
and i thought bill oakley's comment
was pretty profound you know what i mean
like you know bill is kind of a a
comedic character and i i thought i
really liked the way that not only that
that he delivered like what he was
saying but also the way he delivered
this
because you're thinking wow even bill
oakley feels this way this is serious
you know what i mean yeah and he said
there's there's proving and then there's
knowing
and that's kind of
the world that you know when you think
about it like if you zoom all the way
out
that's kind of where saul goodman
resides isn't it he just
he just he likes to skirt that area of
like yes these people are guilty but
you can't prove it yeah and he he can
clean up his tracks physically but
that'll never stop people from being
able to look at him and know who he is
he was able to clean up all the evidence
so chuck could not prove that jimmy
messed up all of his mesa verde
documents but chuck went to his grave
knowing the truth
yeah
and that's really jimmy's that's his
core right is that you know we hurt we
saw that with that that whenever he had
his uh
explosion on um
i can't think of the girl's name now the
this the uh
the scholarship girl oh yeah i forget
her name but when he basically uh he
sits on that scholarship board that in
chuck's will he kind of left jimmy a
seat at that board
and uh they voted on who would get the
scholarship and everyone passed on that
one girl because she had a single black
mark on her record where she shoplifted
so jimmy gives her this whole speech
about how they're never going to let you
move past that but who cares you're
going to show them you're going to take
every shortcut and if they're on the
30th floor you're going to be on the
50th floor he basically lays out kind of
his whole character arc and his
motivation and tells her that's what you
need to do
yeah it was esposito i think was her
last name i can't remember if it was um
kimberly esposito or something like that
yeah but i mean that that's really his
whole thing right like he can't
he can't escape
his past you know who who people see him
as you know and that was chuck all the
way around right like chuck just was
like
refused to do it you know
he was just he was would never he wanted
to make sure that no one ever did as
well which made him even a little
more diabolical but you know that that's
kind of where that's kind of saul
goodman in a nutshell i mean it didn't
used to be not whenever we whenever we
watched but uh breaking bad but that's
who he's becoming as far as you know
where we're at right now
and uh
yeah it's a bit sad to see him lose that
but he goes over to the nail salon he's
got all these calls coming in
and all of a sudden he realizes that
everyone over there is is happy to uh
employ him for his services because of
what he did and
i noticed here i hadn't really thought
about it i mean i always knew that jimmy
wanted people to like him like i said
you know we saw him going around and
putting a lot of effort into that but i
never had thought about it in the sense
of like he doesn't really care where
that comes from
spooj is just as good as the clerk at
the uh you know at the at the uh counter
right and i think it's a pattern we've
seen
because if you go back to season one
uh we basically the arc we see from
jimmy is that he's trying to be a lawyer
up to chuck standards he takes a couple
of shortcuts here and there he does the
billboard stunt but ultimately his
stated goal and i think the goal inside
his own mind is to be a lawyer that
chuck would be proud of and ultimately
all he gets from chuck is betrayal and
rejection at the end of the season he
goes to see his old friend marco they
pull a bunch of scams together and from
marco he gets love marco tells him that
was the best week of my life and then in
season two
once again
jimmy pulls kim into one of his schemes
and that's the first time on screen that
we see them kiss and that he goes back
home with her and that's at least in the
timeline of better call saul when we see
the relationship start to blossom
so yeah
time and time again we see the negative
and positive reinforcement jimmy tries
to do the right thing nothing works out
he gets rejected negative reinforcement
primarily from chuck
jimmy tries to do the wrong thing he
tries to scam people he gets nothing but
positive reinforcement and here we see
that he's doing his day job at the
courthouse he's a pariah everyone hates
him he goes to the nail salon to deal
with all of his clients that know him as
salamanca's guy they all love him so you
can easily start to see
how again and again the world is telling
him you're supposed to be saul goodman
that's where you're a popular guy that's
where people accept you
yeah and even the love of his life is
telling him that in
these first few episodes although we see
a little kind of a little bit of a break
and you know at least a little bit of a
distraction on her part and that and
that uh as we go on here
uh thank you amber t for the 420 i
appreciate that
and you know um
we are
i don't think we really need to say
anything more about
i think we got that so let's go into kim
kim confronting the people
who are following her you know these are
mike's guys
that was kind of the idea that that that
was around there after a while and
when she sends them away that leads to
the introduction to mike
so a pretty big
i mean these characters have
made it 53 episodes i guess at this
point without ever sharing a screen or a
conversation and and you know it was
pretty
pretty exciting to see this happen i i
whenever i was doing my preview video
last week it i was looking at the at the
promo photos and uh it looked like they
might be in the same place
so
kind of saw that coming and it's pretty
funny just how excited we get not at
seeing a character we haven't seen
before but just having these two
characters on screen together at the
same time
it got me just as excited as when a
breaking bad you know when hank showed
up for the first time and it's like oh
it's hank we haven't seen him in forever
but that's a testament to how great
these characters are we're just we get
to see them interact and that's like the
height of storytelling and television
i'm so excited by it
yeah i mean
they don't really
it's not that consequential
as far as who these characters are
necessarily right uh i mean at least
they're not they're not having a big
influence on each other it's just their
presence like
you know
the the situation has a big influence on
who both of them
you know what they're doing later
you know how they they come out of this
conversation you know compared to how
when they went into it but
you know mike and kim aren't going to be
hanging out you know i mean they didn't
connect here
it's not like
you know there's there's some some uh
you know magic going on between these
two characters it's it's pretty
straightforward you know he's doing his
job
she can see that
she makes this connection about him
being the parking lot attendant which i
thought was
really fascinating um you know she she's
he's somebody that
you know was nobody you know and now
she finds out like i said we were
talking about identity right and who
people are and who they pretend to be
and this guy who she saw at the thing
and never thought twice about also
is the guy who you know saved jimmy from
a shootout like not just you know not
just like
he was at the right place in the right
time but he he
he murdered people
to save jimmy's life you know what i
mean um
and she understands that she understands
that's who she's talking to but he also
happens to be somebody who used to work
at a thing and you kind of saw this look
on mike's face whenever he thinks about
that you know he acknowledges it and
then he remembers like that part of his
life is so over now it's so completely
gone and you feel like kim is on that
same
trajectory right
the life that she had whenever she used
to go to the courthouse and see mike in
his little box
that person is on on their way to be you
know a distant memory so i really loved
how they were doing all that stuff here
yeah i think you know jimmy and kim
think that they can we've talked about
this a few times already during the
stream but they think they can present
this image to the outside world you know
jimmy thinks he can go to the courthouse
and be an upstanding lawyer there uh
but
you never know who people really are
underneath and
you know kim thought that mike back in
the day was just a simple parking
attendant not hiding anything and now
she sees that he's involved in all this
somehow he's like you said he's killed
people
um so
i think it speaks a little bit to that
idea that um
yeah people aren't who you necessarily
think they are on the surface i also
think it's interesting that back in
season five
is that moment of shock when mike finds
out that
jimmy's wife you know kim knows where he
is and knows what's going on and he
tries to tell jimmy that kim is in the
game and here the fact that mike is so
comfortable approaching kim
says that in mike's mind i mean she's
definitely in the game otherwise no
matter how stern of stuff you're made
out of i think you would have gone um to
jimmy and the last thing i'll say about
the scene
is
you know i think i've had the thought a
few times if kim is around during any
portion of breaking bad or even if she's
not but she's around for the next few
years leading up to breaking bad
how much is she sort of a puppet master
behind saul not to say that saul isn't
making any of his own choices
but we've we're seeing her advise him on
how to handle the lawless situation
here mike is going to kim rather than
jimmy and this just feels like it's in
line with that pattern that kim might be
more involved than we would have
initially thought in saul goodman's
business again doesn't mean she's there
during breaking bad we're still a few
years away from that but maybe jimmy
learns a lot from his time with her and
kind of carries that forward in the saul
goodman persona
yeah there it's a lot to think about and
um
you know like that's what i think really
that's that's what really i came away
from this this episode thinking about
was just like you know
these people are going to experience
some some [ __ ] in the next couple of
episodes i mean there's only two more
before the break and i'm not sure how
much the break is like a you know a
mid-season
uh you know finale kind of thing but
i feel like something is certainly going
to happen in in you know within these
next two episodes and
seeing mike in in and where how he's
been
transformed and
we know we've been watching kim's
transformation you know like things are
changing
by the end of this episode jimmy is
pretty much superficially saul goodman
you know he's got the he's got the strip
mall office he's got the
uh you know
he just needs to get his car and
francesca i guess you know and
everything will be there on the surface
but something profound has to happen to
the man inside you know like yeah
to to
dash away this part that is clinging on
to kim in a way that you know is as his
is his you know his north star or
whatever the thing that he you know that
that guides him like what he's what he's
motivated to
to uh you know protect or or or try to
someone to build something with like
some at some point that that gets
blinked out it doesn't really exist as
far as we know
and um
yeah you know and i thought about that a
lot with mike and nacho too in the last
episode
how they came together early on and
whenever nacho was trying to get out and
mike was on his way down you know what i
mean so there's a lot of this these
characters are you know seeing these two
together there's a lot of these
characters going in different directions
or
going somewhere
where it's not really related but you
can pull on on the different things that
are happening like you know when you see
it in the two different characters
sitting there face to face
yeah they're all at different points on
their journey down
bad choice road and often when you're
cutting back and forth between the
parallel stories there'll be thematic
connections between them even when you
look at last week's episode where on one
hand you have jimmy and kim pulling this
scheme to clone howard's keys and on the
other you have nacho facing his day of
execution and it would seem like those
two stories have nothing in common but
then you look at nacho as a character
between a rock and a hard place and you
realize that jimmy is in a similar
situation where he's having second
thoughts about going after howard
and it feels like he needs to justify
why he's doing it he feels a little bit
trapped too
so
yeah there's always even when characters
appear to be in very different
situations there's always ways to relate
them oh and one more thing uh minor
correction in case anybody was
heartbroken to hear you say there's only
two episodes left before the mid-season
break there are actually three episodes
left there'll be seven in part one and
then six in part two oh that was that
was definitely wrong there um
so so it's a it's a
oh yeah it's a seven and a six yeah nice
i was i was uh i hadn't thought about it
too deeply until i said that but i just
sort of assumed and um that's that's
good to know i i i don't think it's
arbitrary you know they they could have
went on six or seven and they chose
seven you know what i mean so i do
imagine that something's gonna happen
i just don't know if it's gonna be like
you know
4a
or 5a 5b of breaking bad like where
they're basically you know written as
two different seasons almost right
all right so really quickly um amber t
says
thank you for the 420 again by the way
uh thoughts about what's going on with
the magical company um
in relation to what's happening right
now
i'm not really i'm not really sure
the there was that scene with peter
schuler air schuler last season
he's stressed out because of the
you know the the fact that the um
the lab is built that's right yeah
and they've got a lot of money tied up
on that um do you have anything that
the do you see how that's
going how that's affecting anything
that's going on right now i mean
honestly yeah it's something i have to
think more about it just it feels so
like i'm so focused on every everything
we're seeing in these last few episodes
i haven't really thought about that i
mean i'm sure we'll see it again if i
had to bet because
well i guess i i wouldn't take anything
for granted but
it just feels like it's got to come back
at some point like in the bridge between
where we are here and better call saul
uh you know to where gus and mike and
and lydia are in breaking bad i just i
imagine we're gonna see some of that
bridge
but it's not obvious to me what it's
going to be so i don't know for me this
is a question mark right now
yeah by the way i just i love amber your
um
your choice of the amount to donate each
time and how consistent it is
yeah it's almost like it's an important
number for you or something
but yeah i don't know i mean like i
think
i think that could play a part i mean we
have the whole idea of are we going to
learn more about what happened in chile
and uh you know it seems like air
schwaller was part of that so it could
come in there i mean we sort of know how
lydia's story ends up but a lot of
people were wondering about like if they
were going to
close you know the story of the
construction how they were going to deal
with that i kind of think that lalo
lalo is going to be looking into what
was going on there
that's sort of where i'm at with that
character so it could definitely come
back up in that you know what i mean
it's but yeah right now it's a little
it's a little disconnected
because gus is so
which we're going to talk about in a
second here you know he's so caught up
in
this idea that lalo might come for him
right but but thanks for the question
and and uh you know we'll see if that
comes back up
larry
quarter wits thank you again for the
five dollars this is about what we were
talking about a second ago
ago about kim i think she see she sees
he started out straight just like jimmy
and herself
they all break bad do you think that
we'll get a full episode of gene's
timeline
um yeah i mean that's a take on that and
i i i don't think that i think i saw
some other people who felt that felt the
same way um
about about her noticing that that that
he's in a different place to me the way
i read it was more of like this is just
a person this is he was no one and
i found i'm finding out that there's
something else to this character
that he's much more impressive than what
i first saw whenever he was sitting in
that little box but
i i don't i don't you know they're both
just takes you know what i mean and and
she may be connecting the dots on on the
fact that they're they're going downhill
in that process um as far as gene's
timeline yes i think we'll get at least
one full episode and maybe even more
um
do you want to want to add anything
there gail
no just i agree i mean maybe the entire
maybe that's the season break you know
the last six episodes is all gene
i don't actually think that i i
definitely think yeah at least a full
episode it just feels like
that's where the story wraps up
and
it's to me it would just feel so odd if
we didn't get
at least a full episode exploring that
timeline and doing that story justice
you know
yeah i
i mean the the lazy
kind of just
well there's 13 episodes in this season
so
maybe three of those are for gene
you know it kind of makes sense though
too you know what i mean yeah like it
you know that we don't really know
i mean there is some
there you know there was you know people
obviously follow when they're when
they're filming the show
they're they definitely shot gene scenes
that and it looked to be more
um
more involved than in previous years and
i think um
one of the interviews that bob did
in the new york times that that's sort
of what
led me to think that they're going to be
much more you know at least one whole
whole episode but you know we really
don't know i just think that that's such
a big part about what this show
set out to do like what i was saying
earlier people are saying
oh why do they keep spending time on
jimmy and kim whenever you know it's so
boring compared to the real story this
that is the real story folks and uh
gene is going to be the end of the
better you know the breaking bad
universe that's going to be the final
the final thing that that we see right
so i think
that up and make that matter
yeah and i was going to add just that he
was on the poster i mean that's what
you've got as the image behind us right
now gene putting on that red jacket so
he's got to be an important part of how
this wraps up
yeah
and so you know we've talked about this
earlier and we can get back to it now
gustavo fring
he's got a house we we had seen it
before
it's pretty funny that that scene where
you know walt pulls up and
psyches himself to go and and shoot him
after buying the gun and
all of that
and then he gets that call right on the
thing now we know like what was going on
there right we know how they knew he was
there and
he was able to make that call to tell
him hey just go home or whatever i can't
remember what the actual dialogue was
but
you're not getting in here you're not
killing gus
you know
and we see that that you know we see how
that that really worked out and i talked
about um
you know this in my video but i i've
been kind of down on the gus stuff um
in the last few seasons like i i you
know it it's compelling enough and
i don't think it really made him a
better character in in my mind you know
what i mean um
he's you know
the stuff with hector
it was it was
it made sense i mean i i get where they
were going with it but it just wasn't it
didn't it wasn't my favorite part of
what happened and better call saul
and but i did actually really enjoy this
look behind the door because this felt
more like we're seeing the character
from breaking bad we're not really you
know we're we're we're not really adding
to it we're just we're just seeing what
we didn't see before does that make
sense
yeah yeah no absolutely yeah and i think
um actually it reminds me of something
i've been thinking about which is
this season
feels so different from the previous
seasons and i think part of that is
we're seeing a lot of stuff we haven't
seen before in in a very literal way
we're seeing locations we haven't seen
before or places characters go off
screen we're now seeing like we heard
about howard going to see his therapist
twice a week a couple seasons ago now we
actually see that we've seen a glimpse
of gus's home before but now we're
seeing much more of it than we've seen
before
one of them
yeah true true exactly
and i think as the season gets as a
series draws toward the conclusion you
want to feel like there was a big
journey where you started somewhere and
finished somewhere else and of course we
get that under the surface with the
characters changing so much but the show
also tonally is selling that by just
visually looking so different by giving
us all these glimpses of places we
haven't seen and just taking us into new
territory
yeah
yeah i agree i i really uh when he was
walking down the stairs
it seemed so
silly you know it's like why are they
showing him with this look on his face
carrying his laundry downstairs are we
really gonna watch gus spring do his
laundry like
you know is this one of those
long mic scenes where he you know puts
uh holes in a
a uh
garden hose or whatever you know we're
gonna see gus do something mundane to
show us that he's just like everybody
else and no actually he doesn't even do
the laundry he leaves it there for his
body double because he goes to this um
you know this crazy
wall panel and um
tunnel situation he's got going and i
think it's cooler than lalos would you
agree with that
oh yeah i mean he basically has the
entrance to the bat cave
that's it every man's stream
yeah and then like i said you see him
pass his um
his body double there some guy goes into
his house now
and pretends to be him for the rest of
the evening as far as we know
and and he really operates out of this
this second house and that other family
lives there
somehow they're integrated into the
community like they're not just
they're not just actors but but they
happen to also be what seem to be actors
right so i
i don't really know i mean do you have a
do you have something that you something
inside
i read it a little bit differently so
here's how i read it and then we'll see
if uh if you agree with this but i saw
it as gus walks into his house
and then he crosses underground and goes
into this other home
um i think at this point gus's real home
is now empty
and those actors are talking about i
think that's a real family that
essentially just takes up residence in
this other house
but the idea is if somebody was spying
and looking for gus they would see gus
walk into his house and they'd think oh
he's in his house now
i can't see him because i'm not in there
um is there a chance that he snuck into
some other home well if i check the
house across the street i mean no
there's a family in there so clearly
he's not there
so that's kind of how i read it that's
not actually a body double there's
nobody pretending to be gus
but there's just this second home and if
that second home was empty people might
get suspicious
but if there's a family in there who
would think that
there's his family and gus is hiding out
you know behind the scenes and nobody
knows he's there or that he has a
security detail in there watching
everything through cameras
yeah well i mean this guy is dressed
like gus going into gus's house whenever
he goes into the other one though
okay so let me amend everything i just
said and add that on top of that there's
a body double in gus's house so if
anyone's flying through the window
they'll see that
yeah everything else you said though i
agree with like um
those people
i'm not sure i mean you can't you don't
see enough to really know exactly you
know what's happened i don't think you
could you could say
for sure right but but what stood out to
me though was that they had that little
room downstairs where they were doing
the puzzle they're just living life you
know what i mean
they're not going somewhere else this is
their house
but it's also gus's house right
so um
i'm not sure i i i listened to a little
bit of the insider podcast and they
mentioned it that you know the you know
they are both his houses
and they were talking about that and
i'm not sure if
you know he primarily stays in one or
the other
or if this is just because of the
situation that's happening right now i
mean this is like
he's at war right right so of course
he's going to do something because you
know they have all this surveillance on
the old house and i can't imagine him
living in there
with the possibility of people watching
him like the body double shore he has to
he's playing a part
they're going to watch all these
different angles but like
the whole thing man it just made me
think about like
does this guy ever relax
how would he take a lover you know what
i mean like how would he do anything
normal
at all
in this situation you know and like i
said it's this is war posture this is
maybe a you know heightened sense of of
of defense but like
gus's life is crazy
yeah i think the moment of relaxation
was when he um let his ankle breathe a
little bit when he took off the uh the
gun holster
yeah that was pretty much it
and and i loved how he came when he came
in the front door he was smiling like he
had a huge smile on his face like for
nobody really you know i mean sure
someone was walking the dog by you know
what i mean but like
he had this put on this big happy face
and then as soon as he got behind the
closed door he he let it fall you know
yeah
like he is playing the role
like
even when you don't really need to
um so yeah so he he's he's afraid of
lalo mike points out the fact that
we don't even really know that lalo is
still alive and it does bring up the
question
where in the world is lalo
has anything in this season or this
episode changed your your opinions on
what's going on with with uh mr eduardo
salamanca
uh i mean i mean no to be honest i mean
to me it's still a mystery i'm very i
think i think you mentioned that there
have been some hints
about what the proof is that he's
looking for
i've generally been pretty spoiler
averse i don't watch the next time on uh
after seeing how kind of
loose the people working on the show are
with giving things away which at least
they say we're not giving away the big
stuff i've kind of been very spoiler
averse so for me it's still a pretty big
mystery
um you know i don't know
i i assume lalo is in mexico that's my
impression
because they made a point of showing us
america's that way and he's going the
other way so i assume he's there
um you know but that's about as far as
it goes i really don't know what proof
he's looking for or what his next move
is
and and that's what makes this such a
tense episode for me even as funny as it
all is
he's the ghost in the background he's
the ticking time bomb under the table
and they don't know he's there but we do
yeah i love that i love how you know
that after the after the scam after the
howard thing
the whole rest of the episode is
dominated by lalo who is not there and
who has not been there or made any kind
of influence on on this on the show
since he killed those two
coyotes and
took off back into mexico
right
he's like he's he's like entering that
that that phase of just being a force of
nature you know like being a thing that
uh i don't know specter like i think is
what we were talking about last night
right
um
yeah so
i mean
gossip only
the only thing gus has is his own
feeling and then his
what he got from hector looking at
hector's face but his instincts are
correct here
how does this
where does this go from here
you know
i mean he can't do anything he can't as
far as the cartel's concerned he
everyone's keeping up the appearances
that that lola is dead you know right
so he can't make any moves he can only
wait and and it's pretty it's pretty
it's pretty interesting place to put the
most uh capable man in the breaking bad
universe just having to wait and i and i
loved how they they kind of did that
thing where
he says you know he he's facing all this
he's he's in this crazy situation where
he's
he's he's you know he
his life is under threat in a way that
we've never noticed before and he's
still worried about the quality of of
the workers on the line in los pollos
yeah no that was pretty funny and that's
uh i mean to me that's been
the joy of gus on this show because to
be honest
when we knew gus was coming back i
wasn't particularly excited
because i figured we saw enough i mean
i'm very curious about his past i
definitely am
but i didn't think they were going to
get into everything in chile and start
to explain much of that so i wasn't that
excited to see gus again and wasn't sure
how prominent he was going to be
but for me they did a really good job of
just
making this a really interesting kind of
part two of the gus frank character
study we learned more about his desire
for revenge against hector where it
almost comes off as pathological here
than it does just a personal vendetta in
breaking bad and then
what does gus do when he's nervous just
seeing him break that glass a couple of
episodes ago was like wow he's shaking
we've never seen this before and then
even like you mentioned this little
moment here
where he's complaining that the guy's
cooking isn't to los poyos or mano
standards i just feel like in little
bits and pieces we learn more about
what makes this character tick you know
it's continuing the gus frank character
study where it's less about his past
where did he come from and just at the
moment who is he as a person
yeah
yeah and you know like i said like we
were just we're talking about we we
certainly didn't know that he was
a two house guy who you know was moving
back and forth through tunnels and
and really before it was kind of hard to
imagine him being afraid of anything
and to a certain extent and we've seen
that building up since this first
episode
like i said i don't know where it goes i
don't know
i have some you know some some ideas of
what where lala's going and what's going
to happen with him but
i'm still not really sure how that
affects gus or you know how he's going
to use those things against gus or how
that's going to involve
jimmy and kim because i do think that
they're going to get sucked into it are
we in agreement there
yes yeah i definitely think so
i think you know that's another thing
that i was thinking about in between
episodes was i was thinking you know
this thing with what they're doing is is
really kind of low stakes compared to
what nacho just went through
and like i said i think that i think
that they're going to end up
the stakes are going to get changed not
because they change them but because
they get sucked up into what's going on
with lalo salamanca
yeah i think that's a definite
possibility you know we think of the
stories as isolated in some ways it's
like let's predict what's going to
happen with the howard situation okay
now let's talk about lalo it's easy to
forget that the lalo situation can very
easily derail that howard conversation
yeah and um you know let's get to the uh
i know you said you might have to bounce
out at
half past so
let's get into the
final part of the episode which is jimmy
and kim at the strip mall with his new
office what do you got what do you got
on this one
no i mean just uh it's exciting to to
see another building block towards the
saw goodman we know
this is where we know he's going to set
up shop he just needs to put up the sign
put up that giant statue of inflatable
statue of liberty i love the toilet
being there i mean this show just it's
so funny how it's such an intellectual
and intelligently written show
but it does have this underlying kind of
consistent toilet humor the talking
toilet bag
the golden toilet in the opening of the
episode jimmy clogging the toilet this
season back in episode one or two and
then of course of course when he finds
this office
and kim says you just gotta promise me
you're gonna keep that toilet
so uh yeah it's it is a pretty hilarious
moment and pretty exciting
i think there was a toilet in one of the
ones he was looking at before too uh
when he went into it
sort of has that iconic shot of kim
smoking outside of the place that he was
looking at where he's thinking that
she's coming to
be pissed off at him for what he did and
she says no i want to double down you
know i want to go and do this other
thing and they they end up going and
changing the drawings over
for that mesa verde thing that she
wanted to do i think that might have
been a toilet involved in that scene too
but i didn't go back and look at it yeah
i'll check that i'll report back next
week that'll be my job i'm the toilet
guy i'll i'll keep track
it does make you wonder how they get
that uh inflatable statue of liberty
from the kettleman's do you think we're
going to see the kettleman's again or is
that going to be something that happens
off screen
yeah it's it seems so strange for them
to pop up again like i feel like the
book is exposed we've seen everything we
need from the kettlemans
and we don't we don't necessarily need
to see him go and get the statue of
liberty you know it'd be enough that's
if we get a flash forward or a fast
forward or somehow get to to the point
where he's established here if we see
the statue of liberty we'll kind of know
where it came from
but i mean there's a whole layer to this
where of course i'm interacting with the
show thematically and i really want to
see in a character study perspective
where the characters end up but just
from a purely nerd standpoint of just
loving
just love i love to see storytelling and
how they do it i'm so curious the
overlap with breaking bad just how they
connect how are they going to connect
the shows how do they get us from point
a to point b and the statue of liberty
is one part of that
yeah and i and i loved uh
this was my favorite breaking bad
reference the taco cabeza you know he
says takuka bases right there and we'll
go over there
that was a call back to
whenever jesse and walt were in the uh
whenever walt picks the um
there was a junkyard for their meet with
tuko the first time and and jesse
tells them that you know this is this is
a place where
non-criminals think that you do drug
deals it's a uh it's a situation where
you know
you saw this in a movie or whatever so
you think it's cool and you know really
we i've done most of my my deals over at
taco cabeza because it's out in public
you know nobody's nobody gets shot there
because it's open 24 hours a day and you
know it was kind of
a thing like where you hear taco cabesa
at least for me when i was watching the
episode the first time i think okay i
know that what is that that's something
important from breaking bad and then it
all clicks in my head and it's really
satisfying because you know she
they have to go eat so it's not like
they're you know doing some big
elaborate thing to introduce this
it fits pretty naturally into their
normal conversation and it's a pretty
pretty deep easter egg at the same time
yeah no yeah i agree with that i think
that's the beauty of the easter eggs in
this show i mean they're not fan service
inserted easter eggs it's all very it
would be weird if they weren't there
yeah
yeah and amber t thank you again for the
420 and she thinks that the kettlemans
might be hired for tax stuff ice station
zebra
so um
that's a that's a thought i hadn't had
but it could be they could mention that
um
you know that they hired craig for
something
i mean it's hard to picture just because
i feel like
jimmy and kim both view the kettleman's
as just
not very competent
uh i mean it was really obvious to them
immediately that they were pulling scams
so if they're looking for the best and
brightest to work with
it's hard for me to see them hiring the
kettlebells the kettlemans
yeah i mean really if if there is
justice in this world then you know
jimmy should refuse to employ them
because
because of her her craziness about him
not being a real lawyer and the way that
she rubbed that in his face every time
they have a conversation
yes
yeah so i wouldn't see him uh being too
jazzed about working with her but maybe
um you know
go ahead
i was just gonna say but because kim was
was so harsh with them he did obviously
feel bad like that was you could see
that
right give him the money exactly yeah
so yeah i think that maybe we'll see
that you know maybe there'll be a
mention to like
how he got that off screen or maybe we
won't even see that in better call so
that might be the best route to go is it
just it just later appears in breaking
bad and you wonder how they got from
point a to point b
an enduring mystery if you will so
thanks again amber
larry has another two dollars uh
didn't tuco say why aren't we at taco
cabesa
i don't i don't know i didn't re-watch
that scene that's something that i
remember from before and i and i did a
clip of it yesterday but i didn't really
watch the whole thing do you remember
no no i had to be reminded um about the
whole taco cabeza thing from my brother
adam
so yeah i i it rang a very like slight
bell but i definitely don't remember the
details of it
yeah i i i can't answer that for sure um
but i it's possible that would have been
funny i mean i hope that that happened
in a way
just to make walt feel bad for being
completely out of touch with the
criminal world
so how are you doing on time gail do you
need to
i could go for like a few more minutes
okay so just tell me i'm gonna stick
around uh until
i can't stay all day either but i mean
i'll stick around for a little bit
longer while there's people here um
try to answer some questions i mean
we're pretty much through the episode at
this point
is there anything that you wanted to
discuss that we didn't touch on
uh no you know the one thing that popped
into my mind was in this scene this is
where kim decides not to tell jimmy
about lalo but i think we already kind
of talked about that earlier and why she
made that decision so
and i feel like pretty much
i think that we had a super chat and we
said that we would come back around to
it was that what it was about
oh i think the super chat was that
wasn't that about
what kim was thinking when she saw mike
um about him having been a parking
attendant and then then kind of broke
bad
i feel like that was it and then we did
come back around to that
okay we'll see if we get spammed in the
in the chat that we're forgetting
something
yeah i think that um
we are
yeah i think that that's an important
question and whether it was what was
from that or not is why did she decide
not to tell him and i and i do think
that it's because she thinks that she's
protecting him it's based off of what
mike said i think that she bought into
that
but i i think they might be
underestimating uh
mr mcgill
do you think that there might be
something to that about him about i mean
jimmy is
a master scammer and if if the if the
pulling the sign out at the last minute
didn't didn't prove that i mean nobody
else saw that except for him he did tell
kim right kind of dramatically acted out
but
you know i i wonder if they're
underestimating jimmy and i wonder if
that's gonna be a problem i i definitely
think so he's been it feels like he's
been a passenger for the last few
episodes we definitely see him flex his
muscles i mean literally pulling up that
sign but his mental muscles of getting
out of jams
uh when he was at the country club
figuring out how to get into the
bathroom even after kevin kind of
spoiled his whole ruse
and then here figuring out to move the
signpost at the last second so we've
seen him be smart and figure out how to
do things but we haven't seen a lot of
decision making over what to do
and so
at some point we've got to get that you
know jimmy mcgill's got to wake up and i
think when mike says to kim that she's
made of sterner stuff he's basing that
off of what he saw last season where he
saw the way that kim stood up to lalo
and on the flip side he saw how when
lalo was out there and jimmy didn't know
what was going on he couldn't contain
himself he goes to mike's house and
bangs on the door until he gets answers
versus kim who wants to go about her
daily life
so um
but you have to also remember i mean
jimmy was kind of pushed to the brink he
had just had a near-death experience he
thought that kim's life was in danger
because she's now putting herself in the
game where she wasn't before
so
it's almost like so far this season has
written it off like jimmy is weak he
can't handle himself and kim is kind of
in the driver's seat right now
but it's easy to forget what jimmy is
really capable of
yeah i mean he's he's definitely
broken a bit i mean there's ptsd going
on and they're not wrong about that but
i just feel like it's so noticeable that
she's making this decision not to tell
them the truth
whenever it's equally their it's their
problem equally you know what i mean
and and she's making a decision because
she thinks that he needs to be protected
that just seems it's sort of like you
know when you see them looking like
they're they're on top of the world on
the bed and you think well okay then
something bad is gonna happen to these
people because
in a tv show whenever they're you know
you see that kind of hubris it means
that something bad is gonna come right
right
i feel like that there's a lot of that
kind of feeling around that decision not
to um tell him the truth you know what i
mean
and and i mean she kind of owes it to
him because you know
if lala does show back up
he's at risk you know i mean
yeah absolutely and i think you know we
mentioned it earlier but i think that is
what if she does eventually tell him
that's what will prompt it it'll be a
situation where she has to tell her
she's forced into a corner
yeah and so we have a super chat from
nick wire for 4.99
how did kim and cliff end up having
lunch together
uh i don't know they really explained
that i think it was a professional lunch
they they you know they have a
um
i i don't know do you did you know i
think well and i'll say uh this will be
the super chat for me to go out on so
after this i'll leave you all in pete
pepper's very capable hands
um but i mean the thrust of the lunch
was that kim wanted to pitch cliff her
idea for establishing this pro bono
practice to help people that can't
afford it uh i have to i mean i'm going
to rewatch the episode in the next
couple of days
but if i'm trying to remember if cliff
said anything along the lines of you
know why are we meeting or what did you
want to talk about but long story short
i think
kim knows cliff and she was able to just
reach out and say hey i want to have
lunch
and talk about something i don't think
there's any reason to think cliff
wouldn't take that call from her
yeah that's the way i mean i don't have
a deeper
um
reason than that either i just think
that they're they they they move in the
same circles
if he if she called him and he was
around he would you know he would he
would be down to meet for a cup of
coffee and that's all it really was
introduced as she obviously pitched him
what's going on
like i said we've touched on it before
but it is it is interesting to see that
he he was on board for this idea um you
know we learned a little bit more about
him that he has a thing that you know
his son was a drug addict and he has
some feelings about that he's seen
people get
you know fall through the cracks of the
system see some of the the weaknesses of
that and you know
if she just went around and told other
people like him
about this idea she could probably do it
without
wrecking howard's life you know that
that part is probably not essential to
what what she's trying to do but that
she just looks right past it there's not
even a an idea but maybe we should slow
down
one other thing before i jump just one
thing i wanted to mention that i thought
of earlier and forgot to bring up
because i've seen a lot of people bring
it up in the chat here and i've seen it
in comments elsewhere but in trying to
predict kind of what happens between now
and breaking bad a lot of people try to
say you know if kim were dead by the
time we got there which saw goodman
really be as kind of chipper as he is he
doesn't seem like a broken man
but i think the easy thing to forget is
that jimmy's greatest skill is putting
on a show
so uh you know people don't just be if
kim died or some horrible things
happened a few years later
he i i could imagine if anyone could do
it jimmy would be the kind of person
that could stuff down the grief find a
way to to move on whether he grieves and
processes and moves on or just kind of
stuffs it down and puts on another
persona to just get through the day
we don't see his personal life we don't
see what he's like behind closed doors
so i don't think there's as much
information in that fact that that um
saul goodman is the way that he is i
don't think we can read so much into
that to predict where kim is or or
you know what exactly happens between
now and then
yeah and i think you know that that is
true
like i understand the sentiment and i've
said it myself that it would be hard to
understand how he you know came back and
wasn't
just devastated by kim's loss
but we also saw him do that right i mean
chuck died and he never
acted i mean he acted weird you know
what i mean but he never processed that
he never moved past it he just he just
spent a few
uh you know
the better part of episode or season
four
not knowing how to deal with it and then
he got sucked into being a friend of the
cartel in season five and and you know
right now he's walking around and he and
he looks like it never happened so right
you know
there is something to that and there is
this you know we have seen into
this house he lives in now that we we
don't really know how he it would
would be you know
such a different kind of idea about how
to you know how to live his life from
where he's at right now either so
you know anything i guess i've said it
over and over and i feel like i broke a
record sometime but it's it's amazing to
me how everything can still be on the
table in a story where we've we're so
invested in these characters yeah i
totally agreed
all right so with that uh pete thank you
for having me on everybody in the chat
thank you for uh chatting with us
tonight
and yeah
well i was just gonna say you know we're
not sure but we'll be talking about
whether we'll do tuesday or thursday but
we are we are kind of committed to doing
this weekly right now is that that
that's where we're at accurate yes
yeah and your brother adam wasn't able
to make it today but he'll be here and
we'll have some other people coming too
so
i just wanted to throw that out before
you left that you know we're we're on
we're we'll be talking about that
between now and then and you know we'll
have more more of this to come
for sure
awesome well uh so i'll leave everybody
uh with you pete thanks everybody for
chatting tonight and i'll see you on the
next one
yeah thanks for thanks for coming out
again and we'll talk soon sounds good
all right so it's just me and i'm not
going to be able to stay forever so
let's uh look at some questions
blues
bluestomiv bluestomiv
199 thank you for that did lalo go to
chile to dig into gus's past i've seen
this pop up in the comments here
and that's really the first time that i
thought about it um
it's a good i mean
there's something to it i mean i can see
where you're coming from
it's just i haven't really thought of it
that way i mean i know it's not one of
the things that i had in mind of where
he might be at um
we could i mean he
gus has a past in chile
i think the question that we need to ask
ourselves is
is it better as a mystery i mean from
the from the writer's point of view not
you know
from what you know practically speaking
is it better that that remains a mystery
and we don't ever really know
or is it better for them to answer this
you know what i mean and um
i guess that's what we'll find out
he could be in chile
i tend to think that he's not
based on some other things like if you
if you rewind back to what he what he
knows about gus and what gus was doing
and how he can pursue answers there
obviously the door has been closed on
nachos so there's really no question
about that anymore and
you know i think it's might this is
probably going to be connected to
germany and what was going on with the
lab but we'll see how that plays out
thank you for that super chat again
larry we got uh larry
uh quarter wits again two dollars thank
you i'm pretty sure a lot of you knew
about gus's past already
yeah they do they they know something
about chile
hector called him
el capitan i think is the way he
referred to him and
he didn't they killed max but not him
because of who he was um
because of his past i feel like we don't
we don't know what that is or why that
is but
it definitely they definitely did you
know they they that that definitely
bought him some extra time and maybe
even was the reason why they didn't just
kill him in the first place but they
took a meeting with him
so i agree with that
i'm going to try to look at your
comments here and see what else pops up
um
let's see
i i think
i saw you guys were kind of battling on
whether it was a a a
a
boring episode or not and you know that
that's that's a thing you can you know
you
not everything is for everyone and i
think though that this is not i would
not i would i would say that if if
you're feeling like there is a
it was too boring or not enough happen i
think like look under the surface a
little bit of what's going on with the
characters because
that's really where that's really what
makes this
show stand out from others you know what
i mean
of course they can do action and they
can do that well and we saw that they
can do tension and real propulsion with
the breaking bad series
but they're doing something different
here that
gives you those same kind of rewards
whenever whenever things do happen you
know things matter when you get to you
know think by the time stuff happens
things matter as in as how you feel and
you react to the characters going
through them
and i think that that is a
you know that's what i prefer you know
whenever when it comes down to it
polly bottick says i want to see wendy's
backstory i think that they had a um
they had a little webisode about her
didn't they
does anyone remember
i feel like there was something during
the breaking bad time period where we
saw
something about wendy that was not what
what happened on the actual show like we
got a little bit more of an idea of who
she was
which i mean spoiler alert she's a
meth head you know i mean
it's it's a sad story of
i'm not i don't want to
you know write her off as you know being
a bad person or something like that but
here we have one pete peppers what do
you think about kim and
jimmy
driving howard to suicide i see people
say this all the time and
i mean there's a reason why it keeps
coming up i guess there's a possibility
of it it's not really where i i saw it
heading
i feel like howard is kind of been set
up as the big bad for
kim
[Music]
for a long time
so does that improve or does that does
that resolve her story if
she's
if she kills him
i mean obviously you're talking about
accidentally she's not trying she
doesn't go out to try to kill him
but he dies as a as a result of their
their
um
plans or he kills himself because of the
of what that that happens
it's hard for me to connect those dots
to where i think that would be the most
satisfying end or the way that he would
serve her
story in the most satisfying way but
it's certainly possible
i mean you know
they're they're messing with things and
and you have to imagine that that's
going to get out of their control and
there's going to be consequences so he
may be that
let's see what else we got here well
dante's visit to saul's office
connect the dots to jesse and hal
um
i may have missed this is dante a known
character from breaking bad because i
didn't catch that if that's the case
i believe that we have we have
crazy8 he is a ci we saw how that
happened we always knew that he was
working with um hank
and whenever
jesse brings up
going to to see um
saul the first time
we're kind of seeing how that you know
how his reputation was out there you
know in this episode but we but he also
said that he got emilio is that what it
was the guy's name who was crazy eight's
partner off in the past
so you're saying that he's
that dante was his good friend yeah
that's news to me that's cool i didn't
catch it i have to watch these and make
the video all in one day and then i
didn't you know i try to go back and
pick up all the uh
the the things and i see someone else
saying that dante is not combo he's
definitely not combo that's a character
we haven't seen in the bcs um
timeline so
i'm not really sure because i if
if he was i don't i didn't catch it
and so
um you know i'll just have to look into
it after
i get off of here because
i didn't i didn't you know like i said i
i make these all in one day and
i try to catch everything but sometimes
stuff slips through
uh we see here a howard fan i think
howard will turn kim over to the cops
this bar her and she kills him before
that happens
um
everybody leaves howard out of the
characters they want to see story play
out but i'm interested to see what
happens with him as well
yeah howard's a weird character because
we like kim and kim has an issue with
him and i think that you know when i
rewatched the series this time i i was
surprised at how how dirty howard kind
of was in the beginning like not dirty
and like he was doing like crazy things
like criminal things but
we weren't supposed to i think the way
that they wrote him was that we weren't
that you know that we were supposed to
think of him as this you know
kind of bad boss and kind of just a
lackey for for chuck and
everything was handed to him in life you
know what i mean
i don't think that he was supposed to be
particularly sympathetic at that point
and as as it developed
the last couple of episodes they've made
that effort to do that and i see a lot
of people respond to that
as we see here and i think this is a
good way of wording it you're interested
to see what happens with him as well i
am too
i'm not in the i'm not in the category
of the of the person that i see a lot of
times in my comments who are like howard
never did anything wrong why are they
going after howard i believe howard is a
complicated human
type character like the rest of them and
he definitely did some wrong as far as
i'm concerned like he's not he's not
completely uh you know cool what's nice
about howard where he's at right now is
that he he was broken by the chuck
situation too
but he did something about it and you
could say well yeah of course he did
because you know that
he was able to and jimmy wasn't and
whatever you know what i mean but like
i think that does make him a lot more
sympathetic that he that he that he did
something about it he actually tried to
bring jimmy in at hhm you know even
though it didn't really make sense
anymore
and so you know that there's things to
like about him but he's he's he's
definitely
he's definitely no no angel either
yeah i see someone saying here howard is
reaching out for help and he and he did
and i you know i thought that was a
pretty interesting thing that we saw in
this episode about how
at therapy he was talking about his wife
and
i liked how they wrote that how you know
you see that he has real you know he
sits down he unbuttons his button and he
gets comfortable he gets into the
feeling he talks about that for a second
and then
you know he just sort of
starts talking about a dream he had
which is pretty
you know arbitrary you know like not
really
i don't know i think they were trying to
point out that he's
you know he's he's he's got this stuff
going on but he's not you know he's not
really a hundred percent ready to
to take it on had you know
actually deal with it either i mean
that's the way i took it
let's see um what else we got here
yeah this is in breaking bad didn't saul
say did lala sent you yeah he did say
that and also
this is the ongoing thing that
hector you know
gus told hector that the family line
died with him so
you have these two a you have these two
um
two competing things either he either
he's dead
or he's not and who do you trust more
who do you trust that knows better you
know gus spring or or jimmy mcgill
d-town 902 says that it was a filler
episode um
okay
filler episodes are important
character development is important you
know i mean i think that's what people
call filler episodes when it's not just
all action
whenever the the characters talk and you
learn about what's going on inside of
them and why they're making their
decisions
seems like people like to
call that filler and that's cool you're
watching the wrong show though you know
what i mean like you can watch it
because you like
breaking bad and you like these
characters they want to see what happens
to gus and that
but you know this is this is the show
that
the show isn't doing something that it
hasn't already done i think actually
five and six seasons five and six have
really stepped up as far as the way that
they've been paced and the way things
are developing so
you know i i don't
i'm not sure
i don't i thought this i thought this
was a hard place for an episode to fit
in the season that had this big thing
that happened before and i think that
they did a great job of transitioning
from something super heavy
into whatever comes next
but you know you're everyone
you can like what you like you know i
mean like
there's no right or wrong in that it's
definitely subjective
yeah
i hear i hear you uh
joe han who says it's a freaking
character drama
that's what i that's what i watch it for
but
the other stuff is fun too like i said
the comedy you know you think about like
how funny breaking or how funny better
call saul is and how it also couldn't
really
pull that off if it wasn't a drama you
know what i mean like
comedies are written completely
differently like i don't think that um
i don't think that you know they they
can necessarily do that for 30 minutes
if they could write a tight comedy that
hit that way
but because they're doing a really good
character drama they can they can
introduce these comedic elements and
they work to
you know they they work to uh
enhance that they can they work hand in
hand with that in a way that you know
that's what
that's why all that stuff's important in
my mind
um i i've seen some people commenting on
ozark and i don't
i i didn't get to i didn't get to see
the the the
finale i didn't get to see the final
episodes early and so i i contacted them
and told them that my schedule was
really busy and i was probably not going
to be able to make a video if i couldn't
get them and they didn't answer me so
i'm not sure that i'm going to be able
to fit a ozark ending video in my
schedule this week i didn't get to
finish watching it until sunday i was
already working on my nacho video and i
haven't had time obviously yesterday i
did my
episode 4 recap today i'm doing this
not sure where ozark can fit in in that
yeah this we see uh
another one here about
kim's fate
and yeah i mean it
that
that is what that's what we're here for
right now at this point that's the big
question i think i mean we know jimmy's
gonna become saul that part's already
been decided we know that he has to lose
something
you know he's already got the
superficial stuff
everything's in place for him to become
saul but
you know he's on a slippery slope and on
that on that trip like some things have
to happen to pull some of this humanity
or this you know this this jimmy
mcgillness out of him and you know
that's got to be kind of connected to
kim
but like gil and i were talking about
earlier we don't really know where
you know there's this whole other
question of like who is kim you know
like we know who she is in relation to
what she's done so far
but there's a lot of background we don't
know about her so we don't know if she's
moving
you know if you see you think about
breaking bad the idea of it you know
like how or uh walter white he
he embraced this thing that was inside
of himself
after he got this cancer diagnosis which
let him just let go and and just become
this awful person that he you know he
always had the potential to be
jimmy mcgill we see has you know he he
he's he's been a low-level scammer but
he's also
has the ability to do the right thing in
certain situations so you know what i
mean and
he has a heart as the way that they
would describe it so
you know there's always a question of
like
we know who you become but you know but
what does that mean like what does that
mean under the surface and with kim we
don't we can't really connect the dots
yet because
we don't know if she's becoming if she's
embracing something that's always been
there or if she's just backsliding
towards something that she was before
but she hasn't been being since she
worked at um mesa verde her at hhm you
know and since she worked her way up and
became this really fantastic lawyer
um this one says everything points to
kim remaining in jimmy's life during
breaking bad ice station zebra the
topper in saul's
house her desk insults office and
breaking bad i wouldn't be surprised if
that's not the way they go
i don't know i mean those are all those
are all pretty those are all things that
jimmy could still have in his life
without her actually being there
physically
they have the ice they have the you know
throughout the whole series since they
got the ice station zebra checked that's
been sitting in their bedroom on the
mirror so that's not like some obscure
reference that only she would get
um the topper and saul's house that to
me feels more like a thing that she
might have left behind when she was gone
because that was really important to her
and i don't think she's there
so the fact that it's there
that makes you wonder you know that
that's a whole different thought you
know a whole different process of
thought there
her desk in saul's office i don't know
about that i never i never knew that to
be a thing but
it's a good question
um i i've never been on board with the
idea that she was there just because i
thought it would feel kind of funky to
try to
work that in
um
you know we have that flash forward with
405 where there's a call that almost
feels like it has to be from her
if she was still in his life why would
she be calling a random phone you know
is she in prison is she on the run
why is she you know why do they have
this situation where they can only talk
to each other
on a certain day his birthday at a
certain time
on a certain
pay phone you know those are questions
that that go through my mind
i'm starting to agree with others in the
chat that if kim died saul wouldn't just
be living normally in breaking bad he'd
be a wreck or at least abandon his life
in my opinion
yeah like i said i understand that i've
said that i'm sure that if you go back
and watch my videos
uh there that i mentioned that
exactly that in that way
i get it
i'm just saying that there's also
another thing where he
uh you know i'm gonna this guy you're
gonna get yourself muted if you uh
if you do that
that's not cool
um
so yeah there's this other thing of
where his brother died and it really
affected him and
nothing happened he he doesn't on the
surface doesn't seem to be a different
person because of it we know it because
we see his internal life and we see
what's going on you know behind closed
doors but regular people don't
it was actually a thing whenever you
know the they didn't they didn't give
him his license back the first time
because they didn't think he felt bad
about chuck dying
you know
let's see what we got i'm gonna have to
wind this up soon we're got two hours
here and um
i'm i'm i appreciate everyone being here
and uh it's pretty exciting to think
that 600 of you are still here after
the main thing ended but i just i do
have to uh
i do have to end it at some point
uh someone asks what do i think the hg
wells me books means uh this is a book
that i was familiar with like from
not childhood necessarily but
adolescence i guess you know like i i i
hadn't i i actually
after the first episode and i saw that
it was sort of the first um
flash forward pre-easter egg kind of
thing
i listened to it and i and i don't know
i i don't really understand what what
they're going for there i've seen some
takes on it
people who you know i'm not a i'm not a
literature guy i read a lot of books
because i enjoy them but you know i'm
not i'm not someone who
went to school for a got a degree in
literature or something like that where
i like to
discuss it that way but
yeah i reread the book the the detail i
mean the the deal is
a man he builds a time machine he goes
into the future and he sees that
humanity's broken up into two different
groups like they've evolved into two two
totally different things
and i'm not really sure what that has to
do with um
with the current situation of better
call saul
so what else do we got here
uh
i think kim was from nebraska yeah she
she's from
she's definitely from nebraska
yeah that it's red uh i forget red cloud
i think junior high was the name you saw
the nebraska plates if you look that up
that's a city on the border of nebraska
and um
new mexico i guess right but i don't
uh
i don't know what that means for
anything because they made a point of
jimmy not picking
omaha nebraska that ed disappear
you know he he he sent him there that
was not that was not jimmy's choice so
if anything it's a coincidence you know
mary andrews is asking about the
diamonds in gene's closet
i'd like to know where he got those i
mean i think that would be a fun thing
to see
one of those pre-easter eggs again but
this one you know
some see let's see something in this
season where he actually picks those up
i mean i think that's just a store of
value for him like something he can have
that he can sell if he needs to
you can carry it um
there were huge debates about how much
money that was actually you know if that
even made sense and you know i'm not i'm
not sure i don't currently have any bags
of diamonds i can't tell you
how big one has to be in order to be a
good escape plan but you know i think
the point of it in the story was for us
to know that he has you know a backup
plan he has a a you know a breakout bag
kind of thing he has a way to
you know if everything else gets cut off
he has something there that he can fall
back on
all right so i'm gonna go
about five more minutes so if you want
to point any questions
you can try to do that
let's see what we got here kim's name is
fake when she got married no middle name
there's been a lot made up about that or
there's a lot of people talk about that
as that's a really important story point
i'm not sure it is it could be
it seems it does seem funny that they
that they made a point of of saying that
you know the judge
that married them brought it up
but i mean a lot of people don't have
middle names too so you know i don't
know that that's a
i don't know that's
a for sure thing i was thinking the
other day uh you know if she if she does
have a fake name
what would that mean if she has to run
you know like what she she's she's got
she passed the bar you know i mean she's
she's a
kim wexler is a
lawyer
on the run you know her version of gene
takavic
would not be um
so the whole idea of
you know what is uh you know what is is
she
is she scamming jimmy is she does she
have this escape plan or whatever
there's a little bit of mix there's a
little bit of cross wires than that if
she's if she's if she's doing what she's
doing to
scam him and take off then she can't
really be kim wexler anymore after she
goes
maybe we'll learn more about kim's
alcoholic mother i think that we we
probably will or or maybe her father
even something that you know he doesn't
seem to be involved in her life um
i wouldn't be surprised if we didn't get
another kim flashback
to a um
you know different part of
her i don't know if it would be the same
like you know the same age or maybe a
different time
i hope we do anyways
uh i'm not going to make up a middle
name we'll just say i don't have a
middle name
what do we got here what do we got here
kim is the guy who knows the guy who
knows the guy i'm pretty sure that's uh
you know i'm pretty sure that's uh mike
but
we could be wrong on that
uh we got one here will kai reappear i
think it's a definite possibility
if you go back and you watch
whenever he calls um
werner whenever lalo calls verner at the
resort
kai's name comes up so that's the thing
that well that's a thing that lalo knows
that's
some of the information that he got from
werner before verner
was killed
and he's trying to find proof
that gus is working against the cartel's
interests that's that's what he needs to
do
gus makes them so much money that they
will not
let him move against him under any
circumstance unless they finds out
unless they find out that he's um
he's doing something that they they
can't stand for
uh so yes who kai is kai was the the
idiot german the one that gave mike all
the problems and that mike punched in
the face right before he sent away in a
car
at the beginning of 501.
yeah i mean
kai
kai kai
he was not a he was not the kind of guy
you would trust i don't think i mean
he's he's kind of an ass and
he might he might
he might be mad about the fact that mike
punched him in the face or that they
killed his his boss and his meal ticket
i mean that's the guy he worked for
you know so
we're gonna wrap it up here um
if you have any other questions you can
leave them in the comments here and i'll
try to get to those at some point
do check out my other better call saul
videos if you're new here and
make sure you check out gill's channel
he's got
his the links will be inside the um
the description here
and him and his brother do a podcast if
you want to listen to that as well the
sulcast that you can find i think just
about anywhere you can find podcasts
i'll be doing my
episode 5 preview and
i'll be working on that tomorrow so
that'll come out
maybe this time
if i can get it all finished and
i really do want to thank you all for
showing up
it was a lot of fun i like to be able to
talk a little bit more about what's
going on because
when i'm writing a
10 15 20 minute video i have to kind of
streamline things and i don't get to
always have a conversation
and it's fun to be able to answer some
questions too so
thanks for coming out i appreciate it
make sure you like the video and
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon